avec nous l'analyste en énergie jean
françois blain bonsoir l'union vous avez
participé à la commission parlementaire
qui a eu lieu sur ce projet de loi 34
vous avez dit que rien n'indique que les
os qui aurait été accordé par la régie
de l'énergie d'ici 2024 aurait atteint
les flat sion au dépasser l'inflation
probablement que les os auraient été
plus basses dites-vous selon vos calculs
pourquoi vous dites ça ben écoutez quand
on essaye de sur une base prévisionnelle
de d'estimé quel aurait été le résultat
d'un exercice tarifaire usuels par la
régie il faut mettre dans le collimateur
d'abord les prévisions de vente et plus
réaliste possible
l'augmentation des coûts de chacune des
trois composantes du tarik les coûts de
production de transport et de
distribution d'eau même que les besoins
de revenus qui résulterait des volumes
de ventes prévues
et quand on tient compte de toutes ces
données là la façon la plus objective et
réaliste possible
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que en
2020 en fait on aurait probablement
beaucoup mieux qu'un gel tarifaire une
baisse de l'ordre de à peu près un demi
pourcent 1,6 pour ça et que
cumulativement sur cinq ans les
décisions que rendrait la régie compte
tenu du contexte actuel serait
avantageuse pour les consommateurs par
une marge importante c'est à dire
environ 500 millions de dollars
regardons les chiffres que vous avez
préparé le projet de loi 34 en 2020
prévoit un gel 0%
vous dites qu'avec le processus de la
géorgie régis est ce que vous venez de
dire on aura une baisse de 1 6% 2000 21
22 23 24
le scénario du gouvernement à
l'inflation ces 1,7 par annick six
monoplaces d'hypothèses processus de
régis 1,15 2,8 en 2022
oui mais plus bas en 2023/2024 donc ce
qui est important c'est la moyenne
annuelle cinq ans sur cinq ans 1,39 et
vous avec le registre et 1,1 et le
cumulatif 6,93 % avec le projet doit
34,5 points 52% pour le processus de la
régie donc vous arriver à ce résultat
prévisionnel comment comment vous
arrivez à faire cette prévision là sur 5
ha bon alors il faut il demande d'abord
tenir compte des volumes
de ventes qu'on peut prévoir dans un
premier temps des besoins
d'approvisionnement pour satisfaire
cette demande là donc ce sont des
données publiques ce sont des données
publiques on se base sur l'historique et
les données les plus récentes de même
que les prévisions déjà des remises en
preuve par hydro québec
tout récemment non pour son plan
d'approvisionnement des dix prochaines
années qui concordent d'ailleurs avec
les prévisions que j'avais utilisé sur
cinq ans presque tout à fait exactement
ensuite on a on regarde l'évolution des
coût de chacune des trois composantes du
talent et les coûts d'approvisionnement
les coûts de transport des coûts de
distribution et on projette selon les
moyennes les plus réalistes
selon la réglementation en vigueur selon
les tendances historiques la croissance
de ses couleurs ça donne un motant total
qu'on appelle les revenus requis / le
volume de ventes prévues vont nous
donner un tout unitaire pour chacune des
années il le tonita qui correspond
finalement aux revenus unità moyens qui
résultaient de l'équation nous indique
quels seraient les variations tarifaires
selon l'exercice réglementaire
conventionnelles selon les données
actuellement disponibles et selon les
besoins d'hydro-québec sont ils besoin
d'imposer les projets d'hydro-québec
aussi tout à fait les projets de
production là pour l'instant pas de
grands barrages au genou je ne sais trop
de se dire que les projets de production
de se traduisent pas nécessairement en
coûts d'approvisionnement pour la
division distribution uniquement pour la
part des approvisionnements qui sont
requis pour la croissance de la demande
des clients québécois donc vous arrive
et puis on va le voir avec le deuxième
tableau
vous arrivez donc un coût supplémentaire
pour les québécois de 978 millions avec
la loi 34
le crédit de 500 millions que le
gouvernement d'y retourner vous
soustrayez le résultat net donc c'est
470 presque 500 millions effectivement
parce que dans le calcul de l'écart de
968 millions favorable en fait une
réglementation par les régionales en
compte du projet de loi 34 ya la remise
du 500 millions en question de 500
millions que le gouvernement prévoit
propose deux crédités en 2020
c'est pas un cadeau c'est pas une remise
c'est le sol des comptes des cars qui
appartient au client et qui aurait de
toute façon été remis dans les tarifs
dans le cadre du processus
d'établissement des tarifs habituels
donc vous pensez vous prévoyez que les
québécois vont finalement avec ce projet
doit payer un peu plus cher pour leur
électricité et non pas un peu moins cher
près d'un demi milliard de dollars sur
cinq ans évidemment à condition que les
prévisions d'inflation qui conte qui
sous-tendent le scénario président du
gouvernement se concrétise
ça pourrait être pire ça pourrait être
un peu moins parce qu'un virus est là
juste pour vous dire en ce moment
l'inflation est davantage autour de 2
oui alors si on était à deux ce serait
pas cette fois encore un petit peu plus
cher effectivement et l'écart se
creuserait se le dise si l'économie
ralentit et l'inflation pourrait tomber
exactement et l'or pourrait peut-être
payer moins cher en fait ce qui risque
d'arriver si c'est vraiment peu
avantageux surtout en période de
récession le ministre sera le seul à
pouvoir à sa discrétion demander la
tenue des dossiers tarifaire dans les
cinq prochaines années donc si
l'actionnaire gouvernementale se
retrouve dans une situation d inflation
nulle ou de récession
il pourrait juger que les augmentations
sont insuffisantes et demander c'est le
seul le seul authorities ministre qui
sait qu'il a seul la pourront s'exercer
sinon la régie de l'énergie au lieu de
faire un travail à chaque année il faut
faire un travail au bout de 55 ans et
dans 5 ans évidemment il ya deux
possibilités soit que dans les cinq
prochaines années la croissance des
revenus d'hydro-québec générés par des
tarifs ajustés à l'inflation aurait été
plus rapide que la croissance de ses
coûts auquel cas elle va se trouver à
générer plus de bénéfices plus de
rendement excédant ce qui aurait été
autorisé mais la régie n'aura pas
autorisé de toutes façons de rome
sans donc que les salles soient
considérés comme des trop perçus et
versé plus de dividendes au gouvernement
à l'opposé s'il advenait que ces coûts
augmentent plus rapidement que les
revenus générés par des tarifs ajustés à
l'inflation mais lol la société d'état
aurait tenté
de reporter dans le temps de participer
dépenses qui sera pas essentiel pour
réussir malgré tout à générer des
bénéfices et verser de dividende à son
actionnaire et on se retrouvera
vraisemblablement avec une demande de
hausse tarifaire assez salé dans cinq
c'est ce que nous verrons merci c'est le
bâillon demain merci beaucoup pour cette
explication jean françois dauré